[Music]
[Music]
hey
oh guys well it's lovely to be here with
you and with you too bills oh it's
lovely to see you dominic how's
everything going
it's going very well if i'm honest it's
it's been a nice week yeah
yeah good yeah it's been going
pretty good i've been kind of enmeshed
in all of these comments and reviews and
things that people have been saying
about the podcast
and wasn't it nice to see elijah wood
last week that was lovely to see elijah
wood
but there was so much elijah that we had
to make it
two weeks worth of elijah woods yeah
we're gonna give you guys
two weeks of elijah or what we were
gonna do was maybe give you like a
shortened edited version that would only
do one week and we don't think
that we should do that because we've got
some more elijah at the end of this show
so we better get straight to the
voicemails dom alright let's have a look
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow
snails hi guys um my name is diana
morgan i'm from ontario
canada i just want to say i love you
both so much and i love that you're
doing this
tuesdays have turned into my favorite
day of the week now um i'm a super huge
fan and i've got a question about
uh when you both went into the studio
with vigo back in 2003 for his
pandemonium from america album with
buckethead
um i just wanted to know what was the
experience like are there any funny
stories
um yeah anything would be great i still
love listening to shadow
maybe and half fling of course um
but yeah anything would be great thanks
so much love you both
that was a great day wasn't it yeah that
was that was
what were we doing that we ended up
there i can't remember what we were
doing before
if it was an official thing or if we had
just met vague
for breakfast or lunch or something
that's definitely what happened
like but i can't remember where we'd met
him but i remember him saying
well we're in l.a you know that yeah i
know that but it wasn't like we were
at an official thing and we knew we were
going
viggo just said i'm in the studio this
afternoon yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
he's wearing that's all he just said i'm
going to studio after this yeah
and we went yeah well come and then i
think he told us i think he pre-warned
us about buckethead because he said he
will
not let you take pictures showing his
face
um and at times he might put a bucket on
his head
or a mask he well he's got a lot of
masks he had like a halloween masternode
he had all sorts he had a bag of masks
anybody who doesn't know buckethead he's
an amazing guitarist but
he likes to wear a bucket on his head
yeah hence the name
yeah it makes sense or he likes to wear
masks as well
yeah max head is not as good a name no
but he told me a great story
he um auditioned for uh
um aussie osborne's band were you there
when he told the story i think so
he said so basically he grew up with
that music
that's why he wanted to be a guitarist
he knew all the riffs
you know back to front play with both
hands done ma
just amazing guitarist and those riffs
is what he grew up with so
he could play it all so he goes in and
they're looking for a new guitarist and
he's auditioning
and he's playing these things and he's
he's not playing it well he's getting
all mixed up he can't remember it
just the pressure of being there with
ozzy osbourne and
he's like oh god i can't play this stuff
and ozzy very kindly said look
why don't me and the band go out we'll
grab a cup of coffee
we'll come back once you've settled in a
bit and he was like yeah okay okay
and they all left and he's like trying
to play it and he thought
i'll put a mask on because he he likes
to play behind the mask you know
so he put a skeleton mask on
and he was he was playing it and he's
gone yeah i'm getting back into it i'm
getting good
door opens aussie and the band all come
back in so he looks up and obviously the
first thing aussie sees is a skeleton
and he says my god man how long have we
been away
[Applause]
i love that um but wait so that day in
the studio
from my recollection you me elijah
buckethead vigo
viggo was playing as a few things this
is half finished yeah
try to work out this and he had said to
us guys he was like this needs a piano
this might need a little bit of guitar
because he knew that we all kind of
were able to in somewhat play you being
at a higher level than
elijah and i and then i think we all
just
at times drifted in and out of the
studio didn't we elijah was sat on the
piano tinkling around
he came back in you played a few things
on
guitar and bass is that right i know
that i'm i know that i'm credited wrong
on that album oh this is a disgrace
because it says i'm playing bass when i
was playing drums and it says i'm
playing drums when i was playing bass
i was very disappointed yeah but my
favorite thing is the
the thing that you and elijah did the
halfling that's the one that she said
that's great that's really fun so we
went in there elijah and i
used to do this kind of voice
i think what happened was it's like a
sarcastic
thing i have it with other friends now
where if something bad happens
it's i i say oh just enjoy it like
someone said i just fell down the stairs
and cut my arm up and i got it just
enjoy it
and um elijah had this thing where they
would come over to us and say
sorry guys you know we're gonna have to
reattach your feet because they've come
off and all this kind of stuff
and elijah and i would both be lost
and we were just messing about with
those voices in the studio weren't we
and it's kind of similar to this i
remember vigo kind of nodding away going
yeah yeah do that do that do that
and then they record as much stuff as
they could and then i think
after we'd left i think between him and
buckhead these were like oh that piano
piece that billy did is great and
yeah like that drum and this guitar and
and it kind of became a thing and then
i don't know about you but viggo then
drove to my house months later with
four cd uh like
boxes which must have been like 200 cds
and he's like here you go this is for
you i was like oh
yeah yeah i think they just arrived at
my house one time
but viggo's really kind that way i
remember one time
he came to my house as well
i think to watch the academy awards one
yeah
and he arrived with a box of books
he just thought there's a box a book
like
you know 50 books yeah yeah yeah thanks
very much
yeah he did something like that with me
one time where he opened up
the boot of his car and just said just
take anything you want
and it was just
it was just like shoes and books and
records and cds and he was like yeah
i'll just take anything
i get the feeling that maybe he was
taking it to goodwill he was like if you
want it
i'm giving it away probably wasn't his
car is that it for voicemails
we're done now we do have some questions
that people have written in
ah should we talk about these questions
now do we have time for that
if you want to ask us a question you can
email us
the friendship onion at castmedia.com or
you can leave a voicemail
at www dot speak pipe
forward slash the friendship onion i
think did i miss a dot there
dot com www.com
no www defense
no yeah it is here we go i'll do it
again right we'll cut this bit out
maybe we won't or you can leave a voice
mail for us
at www.thefriendshoponion.com forward
slash the friendshiponion.com
and the podcast notes you can see it
underneath but you always get it
right it's something about a tube if you
want to leave a voicemail
it's www.speakpipe
forward slash the friendship onion.com
forward slash speak pipe
ah i think it's speak paper.com
forward slash their friendship onion
we've done
it hey oh that was easy
hot flashes from that oh this one's for
billy oh what is that go on bills shall
i read this so that you can answer it
yeah this question is for billy i would
like to hear the story about your song
the last goodbye oh it makes me cry
how did it come about what was the
inspiration really interesting
because when i first heard it it was
overwhelming that i literally cried
marina
i cried too when i've heard that song
billy's voice i'll tell you what i'll
tell you how it happened
i'll i'll do it as quick as i can they
were using the song that i did
in return of the king at the edge of
night they wanted to use
in the trailer for the hobbit battle of
the five armies
and so they sent me a note about that
and i thought it was brilliant i saw the
trailer with the song on it
and i thought what could be nicer it
links the two trilogies
lovely i said oh please do and then we
got into a conversation
who have you got to do the last song we
don't have anyone yet
because it was neil finn before one of
my favorite
songwriters in the world and i said well
you know
i'll do it and then that's quite unlike
you
very unlikely yeah it was only because
it was in the conversation
and then they said well yeah we'll come
down to new zealand then
and i did and then uh working mainly
with a fran walsh
and it took a while you know because we
kept going back and forward with
different
melodies and ideas and
and it was while i was in new zealand
and it was just me
from cast uh
and and i would go to cafes that we
would go to and i'd go for walks and i'd
think
god this really is the
you know we always said there was so
many goodbyes there was so
and it did feel like this is the last
one now this is the end of it
yeah that's sad yeah it was quite sad
and then we came up with that song and
then
and that's how it came it came about so
rather than being an end to that song it
did feel like oh wow this is the end
of this tolkien journey
this new zealand telling of the story
you know and instead of sharing that
that last goodbye with the rest of the
cast as we've done previously you're now
doing it on your own walking around yeah
well until it's probably raining do you
know what i mean yeah it was kind of
weird
you haven't when weren't you having
problems with your gallbladder at that
point
uh was that no that was losing another
time oh yeah
because i was thinking walking around oh
the pin great song fantastic song and a
fantastic
question thank you we've got a a lovely
butter related
comment would you like me to read this
one for you it's from eva from eva
or ava as a child whenever i got a
tick on me whenever she got a tech on
her i don't know if i've ever had a tick
on me
well anyway as a child whenever eva get
a tick on her
her mum would blob a big lump of butter
on it she said it would suffocate the
tick
and make it let go i don't remember if
it ever worked
says eva i just remember several
instances where i had to sit still
and stare at a big lump of butter on my
arm or leg
what a lovely butter related statement
there
there's a use for butter that i've never
ever seen
or heard would it work on my dog
are you trying to suffocate your dog no
no
if you've got a tick i mean roger that
because i was going to say that'd be a
lot of butter
but i mean to cover a terrier i think
i think it's a solid because you can't
breathe through butter and i know we've
all tried it right
so i think the next time bobby johnson
gets a tick you should try it because
the old way that you used to do it was
with a cigarette have you seen that
you give the dog a cigarette give the
dog a pack of 20
and this thing's just full
no you get a cigarette from someone who
smokes and you but i think that's what
they're surely that would get would get
the dog
yeah yeah but it let's it makes the tick
let go i think butters no
of course i would make it let go yeah
but then after the tick fell off
your little dog would have a lovely
treat of uh you know licking his hind
quarters a little bit of butter there
hey don you know it's a great gift for
father's day go on i'm listening
manscape manscape yeah it's the only
men's brand dedicated to below the waist
grooming and their brand new shaving
tools just dropped right now in time for
father's day yeah i just got one me too
the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer it's now
available in the usa and canada
and you know what dom it's waterproof
wow
this 7 000 rpm trimmer features skin
safe
technology to keep your balls in check
and has helped reduce manscaping
accidents all around the world
another thing that prevents accidents
it's got a 4000k
led spotlight that you can turn on and
off when you need it for a more precise
shave it's also got a little button on
it that allows you to
lock it when you're traveling so it
won't turn on in your luggage brilliant
fantastic
additional guard lengths with sizes one
to four to let you trim
to your liking you can get 20 off and
free shipping with a coat onion at
manscape.com this is the perfect package
for you
and possibly your dad's perfect package
that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use code onion get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code onion
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use the
code
onion it's dad board season it's time to
get
smooth do you know what clothing company
i love now dom
tell me things violet clothing
hey i thought they were just about gym
stuff you know shorts
joggies that kind of thing but you can
wear their stuff anywhere dom yeah
they're fantastic they obviously do
board shorts but they do a whole bunch
of different clothing
you were telling me you got some jogging
bottoms and some board shorts
i got myself comfortable a little which
is like a body warmer
i was wearing it yesterday out in the
sun i was gardening i was chasing my
animals around the clouds came out it's
breathable you don't get too hot in it
you don't get too cold not only that
it's stylish enough
i was going to wear it today but i
didn't want you to feel jealous i love
it dom
i also love what the company's about did
you know that they are offsetting
100 of their carbon footprint that's
fantastic and
they actually use some plastics to turn
into their clothing which is absolutely
brilliant
amazing viori is an investment in your
happiness for our listeners they are
offering 20
off your first purchase get yourself
some of the most comfortable and
versatile clothing on the planet at
viori.com
onion that's v-u-o-r-i dot-com
slash onion not only will you receive 20
of your first purchase but you'll enjoy
free shipping on any us orders over 75
dollars
and free returns go to viori clothing
dot com forward slash onion and discover
the versatility
of your clothing we should get into this
now because
we're talking about your dog sorry the
show's going to go so long but you guys
come on we're supposed to make this
really short because we'll get a larger
word later
i want to tell the story about how your
dog tried to seduce me last week he did
didn't he
i came down to billy's last week to
watch is it off
what you know those fighters
i can't remember what we're watching
we're watching the fighters the two
the two fighters they fight each other
in the octagon mma
no off ufc ufc ah that's what we're
watching that's right who came down to
watch you at sorry ufc
and i know your dog well i've known him
for a few years now he's always we've
always been
very friendly with each other sometimes
he'll take a little nap with me
fantastic but he did something which you
and your wife both said he very rarely
does i've never i've never seen him do
it
i've done it to you nope he mounted me
he did and then he climbed up
my torso and my chest
and ended up putting his top legs kind
of on my clavicle
and was looking kind of up and over my
head and i felt a kind of like
you're mine he was very very close to
your face
and he doesn't like to get close to
people's face uh to give you some idea
of the size of my dog he's not as big as
say one of those
uh vacuum cleaners that you would pull
he's smaller than that right just to
give you some idea a good example
so he's a chicken or a small turkey yeah
exactly
he's standing on dom very close to his
face and he never gets close to anyone's
face
and i noticed them touch your face with
his tongue
yeah and he's never done that before
yeah so both
billy and billy's wife said that's
unusual we don't know what's going on
there and then for the rest of night he
was very close to me and then you said
the next day
your wife was thought that maybe i might
stay the night yeah
we were sat up late chatting so she put
out some bedding and then bobby was sat
on the bedding the next day as if to say
where's my mate where's the little sleep
together we were supposed to have a
sleepover
maybe next weekend you can tell him
tonight let's hope so anyway there's a
butter related question
and then a final little question here
from someone this is a lovely comment
uh it says not redacted which is strange
says this show is incredible
also your producer john is a fountain of
knowledge when it comes to middle earth
trivia
now hornet's nest
wide open because i think there was
a little um emoji at the end of that was
an ironic emoji because
john has really let us down yeah he's
sold us down the river i mean the first
couple of weeks we said
john will you deal with the quiz
questions he said just leave them with
me he says
which we did and then he inaccurately
had us tell someone that the ring is
thrown into
bar and we not mount doom and at the
time i remember was kind of going
but john's like no no that's right i've
changed and then who tried to destroy
the ring
at the council of el run and he got that
reset borromea and it wasn't it was gary
and then there was one more i thought
which was a discrepancy oh the
pub in it was just so what we're doing
this week before we do
any more quizzes whether they're lauder
rings based or
anything we need to quiz john yes
so this week before we bring another
guest because we don't want embarrassed
guests
no the way that we embarrassed them
before we are bringing on
john the producer and he is going to be
quizzed
this week and no you know something else
i've seen on the questions and
and comments people are saying it'd be
good if we had a little more music
so you know what i've done tom yeah i've
done some quiz music
would you allow me to please do it i
knew there was a reason why you brought
your guitar
you've got the voice of a lark just to
make a bit more
of the quiz because i think it should be
a little bigger watch your headphones
don't hold on
the voice of a lark and the finger
dexterity of a
young jimi hendrix no don yeah
if we like this you need to learn that
and sing it with me next week
maybe if we like it we can loop it
i'm going to they're ready okay you like
that the way it goes like that dumb
it's quite rock and rolling
[Music]
do you know the answers no to the
questions that we'll ask
do you know the answers
[Music]
oh do you know the answers to the
questions that we'll ask
do you know the answers will you
take the ring
[Music]
it's time for i will take the ring
we have decided to call the quiz will
you take the ring to mordor
so we have to ask and we should get
whoever's on the quiz
to say i will take the ring tomorrow
let's do that then let's do that so
john are you all micked up i am here and
i will take the ring
to mordor but do you know the way
oh here we go john
who's doing the first question how many
will we do should we do you nervous
pretty nervous i was up all night
studying
good there's no prize or penalty
depending on how the questions go should
we do like three or four questions
and you got an easy one to kick off um
yes i'll keep score
there are four hobbits and uh the lots
of rings that uh
they go on the adventure as you know one
of them
is sam what is sam's full name
sam wise gamjee he's
done it he's none of that number over
right no
no no no no no john don't be crazy
that's one out of one
okay john now i actually answered this
earlier on
so if you were listening to the podcast
that we've just been doing today
the answer has already gone out there so
we'll see if you're actually listening
to it
what is the name of gimli's father
gimli the dwarf gimli dwarf had a father
quite a few times
a few characters in the film and the
book say
gimli son of damn lee
it's not right not the right answer
dimly son of of
gambling no again you've said that again
twice that's wrong
no i mean i did have multiple choices in
my questions
oh good point good point i'll give them
a multiple
them you'll choice we've got multiple
choices coming up but the answer is
gimli son of gloin
there you go well here's a multiple
choice then and i'll give you a pippin
question mm-hmm your favorite after the
my very favorite character after the
adventure of
the lord of the rings pippin and mary
return
to the shire pippin gets married
does he marry daisy baggins
goldilocks gondor
rosie cotton or diamond of long cleave
does he marry daisy baggins
detention goldilocks gondol
rosie cotton or diamond of long cleave
all right i uh i believe samwise married
daisy don't get cocky john well you know
that's not the question i'm going to go
with rosie cotton
it's the wrong answer it's diamond of
long clean
as everyone knows one out of three one
diamonds in middle earth here is your
fourth question
all right wait wait you love it oh i'll
on the on the in the spirit of mary and
pippin here you go very
very easy john here we go what are mary
and pippin's last names
full names would be good yeah so that's
multiple choice well you can't get
multiple choice on that one i'm afraid
uh took very good
and
no one ever remembers my character
[Music]
he said he's really searching for it can
i get a clue
yes yes the first part of mary's last
name
is an alcoholic drink very often drank
at the end of an evening with a smoking
jacket and a second
as a type of animal yes
whiskey tiger
but i like it though he went for a
steiner there no it's
merry adock or mary brandy buck
so that's one out of four oh is it one
yeah yeah why would you get half a mark
out of that one and a half
one and a half out of four okay last
last couple of questions each maybe
or one yeah let's do another two see if
we can get up to three come on
i'm feeling good i'm feeling good there
are wizards
in middle earth correct also known as
the estari
there are blue brown gray
and white wizards gandalf begins the
adventure of the lord of the rings as
one color
and ends as another great await
that should be two points for that we'll
give you two
i can't believe you gave him that i like
john i know you don't
well no you're not the way you look
behind it
john i'll give you a choice here as to
the the subject of the question
do you want uh do you want a question
about hobbits
or do you want a question about the ring
i'll do the ring it's just it's a simple
question it's a simple question
is it square
[Music]
[Laughter]
here we go john for all the marbles and
possibly a ring
who made the ring
multiple choice yeah okay multiple
choice was it
sorrow man sauron
galadriel
that was very good john a lot better
than we thought it was
four and a half out of six is that right
dom
actually said that he would be surprised
if you got anything yeah
so that is quite good john john you can
stay another week
do you think we could quiz john like say
for instance once a month
on other things oh that might be fun and
we get to know a little bit about
him what he knows what he doesn't know
we'll get into this
a little bit of stuff i love it i love
it we'll come back to you on that john
but you did very good
that was supposed to be a punishment for
you but it was actually a lot of fun
billy security is a massive issue for
people on their devices nowadays
absolutely we don't know who's looking
almost anyone can view you've got a
webcam you've got all of this sensitive
information on your phone
how do we combat that i'll tell you how
dumb
express vpn that is an
app that re-roots your internet
connection
through their secure servers so your isp
can't see the sites that you visit yeah
expressvpn also keeps all your
information secure
by encrypting 100 of your data with the
most powerful encryption
available so you know that whoever
you've got your internet with
they can legally sell your informations
to ad companies
that's crazy but they can't do that if
you do it through expressvpn
yeah expressvpn is available on all your
devices phones computers even your smart
tv so there's no excuse
for you not to have it protect your
online activity today
with the vpn rated number one by cnet
and wired
visit my exclusive link expressvpn
forward slash onion and you can get an
extra three months free
on a one year package that's e x
p r e s s vpn
dot com slash onion expressvpn dot com
slash onion to learn more this podcast
is sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 48 hours now it's
not a crisis line it's not self-help it
is professional counseling done securely
online
there is a broad range of expertise
available which may not
be locally available in many areas
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
as with traditional therapy visit
betterhelp.com forward slash
onion that's better h-e-l-p
and join over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help
that they are recruiting additional
counsellors in all
50 states special offer for the
friendship onion listeners
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
forward slash onion
[Music]
but john we're not going to let you go
just yet this seems to have been turning
into the john show because obviously
each week we ask people to
send in a song that they think is funky
for them
is it funky to find out if it's funky
for us right funky is it funky for you
is that funky this week john it's you
that's gonna
uh proffer up a song right
yeah so this song it has about four four
kind of relevant
uh pieces as to the show
which i'll kind of let you figure out
please do you want me to name the song
now
or played first yeah let's name this
song so in lieu of this quiz bombing
even though it didn't i chose tom wait's
bad as me album and the song
chicago now i know tom waits i don't
know this song
well he loves chicago let's do it
[Music]
well that well that was an adventure
that's
certainly funky how do you feel about
tom uh not york although we'll talk
about that later but tom waits as an
artist
i love him fantastic isn't it yeah i
think he's very
brilliant and honest and you know
whenever i'm in the studio recording
with him
no with myself or with the band bee cake
whenever we think are we being too weird
putting this noise on
we'll always go let's listen to tom yeah
yeah and you're like
listen to how weird that is i think we
can
you know hit a dog with a tree for sure
and that will be okay
and his voice over the years has gone
from
you know uh quite a melodious
melodious lovely molasses type voice
to now
i think melodious is wrong yeah i think
that means a
very stenchy fish so what was the word i
was looking
a for with melody is there a melodious
it seems as though it should be right
i'm i make up my own words sometimes i
think that's good shakespeare did that
as well
you and shakespeare are very similar
it's true actually um
brilliant that was funky for me i'm
gonna say on a scale of brahms to prince
i'm gonna say that's the rolling stones
very good
i would say that was very good
you absolutely you you won our respect
in the quiz
and then you've only just upped that
respect with that song it was wonderful
and i'll put that up there with
the specials oh that's funky yes that is
funky
he's meant to he's my brother's favorite
artist tom waits and i think he's a good
actor
brilliant great performances and a
chameleon as well
he's great hey dom i think it's time
that we go back
and finish off our little chat with
elijah wood i don't see why not because
you're interesting but you're more
interesting when elijah's around i hear
you dog so why don't we do that but
guys if you want to get in touch with us
remember you can email us the friendship
on you at castmedia.com that's cass with
a k
you can send us a voice note yes please
send us a voice note to
what is it www.speakpipe.com.com forward
slash
the friendship onion and also billy and
i've been asking you for a long time now
if you rate and reviewers and you're
really proud of that review
take a screenshot a screen grab or a
screenshot
of that review send it to billy and i on
our social media page maybe we'll put it
up on our social media page
maybe we'll read it out on the show next
year yeah there's some really nice
reviews
and like interesting reviews as well so
and i know we haven't been very good at
explaining how you do it but once you
write the review
take a screenshot of it stick it on your
instagram and tag us in it
and then we'll re-throw it back up or
we'll read some out on here i don't know
how you do it on spotify but i'm sure
it's there but i think it's easier to
leave reviews on
the apple podcast section there was a
lovely review this week that said i
think dominic monahan is the most
handsome man in the world and i thought
yeah thanks mum i left that one night oh
bills thanks don't worry about it
guys we're going back to elijah wood and
we'll see you all
next week bye toodles
lies do i read this question from nick m
in november
nova scotia canada were any of you aware
or had you seen peter jackson's horror
films upon or prior
to being cast in uh to being cast that a
live
basket case no that would be um he
didn't he didn't make
basket case he made um brain dead
well get alive is brain so dead bad
taste
bad taste i think he's thinking of bad
taste yes frighteners did you
wonder how he'd approach lord of the
rings with that type of background
have you seen those films what did you
think
um i had seen the frighteners
and heavenly creatures same and i think
i i
watched brain dead um
in new zealand and oh what's the puppet
film uh
meet the fields [ __ ]
but prior it was the frighteners and um
heavenly creatures and based on those
two things i remember very distinctly
hearing about
the announcement that the movies were
being made which was probably
1997 that they actually announced that
he was he was embarking on the journey
and it took that time to get it all all
up and running
and i remember thinking oh man that
makes so much sense
because of the mixture of fantasy
and and human drama storytelling
in heavenly creatures specifically i
thought oh that's so
perfect because that is a you know there
is a world a fantasy world that's
present in those characters minds that
they sort of live and exist in
yeah that was so beautifully realized
that mario lanza world yeah
but then also the the the sort of pathos
and
the the human drama of it was so real
and grounded
it just yeah i just remember thinking
about him and going oh man i love that
film
what he'll do with lord of the rings
makes sense how i thought that
oh yeah what about you yeah i'd saw
most of them actually and the one that
sticks in my mind i'm slightly older
than you guys
and uh when i was growing up and
video recorders came out vhs and
you had to go and rent a movie yeah and
the local store
would have a few and there was only
about four or five movies
and for some reason bad taste was one of
them oh wow
it was bad taste the warriors
wow the wild bunch and i
think that that basically that all the
movies
that this store had what a trick you
would basically take one out
you know every week so for some reason
and i don't know why that was one of the
vhs movies
that was you know in circulation because
excuse me the video cover of bad taste
had a very iconic
cover it was the alien yeah that's the
middle finger that's right
it kind of scared me when i was a kid i
was just like whoa that's the box
yeah yeah that looks a little crazy i
watched
beverly creatures once i got to new
zealand i'd seen the frighteners didn't
know it was pete jackson
watched meet the feebles when i was in
new zealand oh yeah and i was a little
bit in the same headspace as you i was
like right okay so
a frankenstein of all of those three
i can make sense of and especially
heavenly creatures yeah yeah i was like
wow there's some real
gravitas to it a grandness you know have
you guys seen the new
kate winslet detective thing on here
mayor of eastern
i haven't seen it yet it's great that's
what i've heard yeah she's great
she's incredible she just has that magic
thing with great actors where you never
see the acting
she's just she's just being you know she
really is
and melanie linsky too yeah oh my god
i mean both of them i think it was their
first feature film melanie i think had
never acted in anything
how was that she was local melanie's
from new zealand you were there on
another project right yeah i've worked
with her twice i worked with her on
an animated show called beyond um
over the garden wall right and then we
made a movie together uh
called um i don't feel at home in this
world anymore which is brilliant
i love that film do you know where i saw
that i saw that in pete jackson's house
did you yeah that's crazy they'd watched
it the night before him and fran
and we were looking for a movie to watch
and said oh let's watch elijah's movie
it's great
and i loved it your performance to that
is brilliant yes
thank you so wonderful it's constantly
put up in the netflix kind of critics
pics like when they do that little
section that movie's in there oh that's
lovely yeah that's really cool
guys yes should we listen to
voicemails from people around the planet
well you get voicemails from
people around the planet yeah it's like
technology we use
if you want to leave a voicemail you can
do that at www
dot speak pipe forward slash the
friendship onion
that's really cool it's cool right so
let's let's uh hear what people are
saying to us this week
hopefully not abuse so say for instance
you you must be on the podcast
next week uh elijah or the week after i
could leave you a voicemail yeah if you
could yeah oh i will yeah good
great all right let's see hey there i'm
really excited to hear this podcast i
think you guys both have great chemistry
in one of the appendices dom you
mentioned seeing elijah wood
tumbling down three flights of stairs i
think
billy you mentioned that the irony is
that his eyes don't really work very
well i was wondering if you could
elaborate more on that story
and also a little bit more on how bad
elijah's eyesight is
if there are any other stories regarding
that i just thought it was really funny
but yeah thanks so much for listening to
this
and i'm excited to listen to the podcast
take care bye
oh it's such a lovely message well this
is so
that was so strange because we were just
talking about this obviously
falling yeah i seem to recall
we were in camperdown
studios or it might have been stone
street i think it was stone street
i can't remember what we're doing but
you were in front of me
and you were looking over your shoulder
talking to me
and you kind of just missed a step and
tumbled
a little bit but trying to regain your
footing
down those stairs and we were laughing
and i was like oh you're okay elijah and
you're like yeah i'm okay and you kind
of
like bounced up and then as we turn the
corner to the next set of stairs
you either did it on purpose or it
happened again
and you jumped up like a cat it was
crazy
it sounds like i did it on purpose first
bit maybe not
yeah that sounds genuinely like i was
losing my footing but the second one
yeah
cause i i i loved and still do love
pratfalls
um i actually took you know the stair so
the the first hotel that we stayed at
where they they put us up before we
ended up getting accommodations
was it the ten points the ducks the
ducks
they've since changed the name of it i
think it's now a different hotel
but it was the duxton then nice one yeah
uh and i remember
intentionally because it had that when
you walked in the lobby
it was a high high high ceilings because
there was a mezzanine that you could
walk up to
there's a big staircase off to the right
that would wound around to the mezzanine
area
and i remember taking those stairs and
intentionally prep falling down those
stairs
wow brilliant about halfway down yeah
but you were very difficult to hurt
i remember once i don't mean emotionally
but um you i remember busy that hurt
emotionally like physically
now i remember we were somewhere
at this sort of seaside because the sea
was there and there was a beach
and you jumped over the wall which was
like this height
you know uh on to the beach but not
knowing that the other side was like a
15 foot
fall and you just landed and laughed and
i remember thinking
when i looked over the wall i was like
oh my god he could have killed himself
and you didn't know it wasn't you just
jumped over and you were all right yeah
yeah it was you're quite incredible how
you can't hurt yourself i think it's
that thing though
when your body knows what's gonna happen
it right braces for the fall which is
actually very dangerous
so they often say that that drunk
drivers walk away from a lot of
accidents because their bodies don't
brace and
you get injured by bracing because
you're holding you know
you're waiting for something to happen
and you go stiff and that is what
actually causes injury
so having not known what was on the
other side was probably to my benefit
because i pushed because it was sand
that helped yeah
because you did recently take a tumble
and hurt yourself didn't you yeah
about two years ago um uh we
my girlfriend and i lived in a place
near downtown that was a
sort of an industrial building it was a
loft space and i
uh she was away we were actually running
a film festival out of our house just
for our friends called the fortnight
friend film festival
um just movies that we had never seen
and we just didn't
like programmed it invited friends over
and it was kind of an open door policy
so anyway i i just watched um butch
cassidy and the sundance kid and i was
on a break between films
um can i just interject yeah at the end
of butch cassidy and the
sundance kid they both take a massive
leap
and ultimately die they do yeah
that's really that's interesting i had
not put those two things together
yeah so go on sorry finish watching the
film um
and i was sitting outside on a break at
about two hours before the next film was
supposed to start
and i thought oh you know i haven't
changed the air filters in the ac units
in quite some time
random i'll just use this time so i
climbed up to the roof
and the property had uh or has
a sort of corrugated plastic roof
material
over some plants that lets sunlight
through
and i just hadn't been up there in a
long time and instead of walking along
the roof
line that was solid roofing i walked in
a diagonal and crossed
over that corrugated plastic which of
course didn't hold my weight
instantly fell through so i stepped over
fell through to concrete below
about 15 feet when you say concrete you
mean another floor
no it was the it was the ground it was a
concrete
concrete floor yeah and uh i yeah at a
small hip fracture
dislocated my left hand from my wrist
broke a small bone
in my left hand which is actually
miraculous considering
the fall the length that i fell i mean
if i'd fallen wrong if i'd hit my head
you know did you make enough noise that
people at the film festival knew that
something had happened to you nobody was
there
so were you like help i was alone so
it was a it was a wild series of events
fell knew i would like you know as soon
as i
felt the plastic from underneath me
buckle i thought okay that's it you know
your brain immediately goes i'm falling
so that happened and then i fell landed
and immediately took stock
kind of oh my dude okay okay all right
up my left hand is dislocated and like
it was like out here
oh i can't move that that's not good
gonna need help for that
i need to call 9-1-1 i need to go to the
hospital this is obviously not something
i'm going to walk away from
so i had my phone in my pocket that i'd
fallen on but managed to
not destroy my phone called 9-1-1
i then had a cigarette nice in a kind of
i was in shock clearly in shock i didn't
feel any pain yet right
um so i had a cigarette kind of like
calm my nerves down because my my
adrenaline was really going i then
called my girlfriend and tried to
sound as extremely as calm as i possibly
could so it's not to scare her yeah and
of course i didn't sound as
calm as i thought i did uh and
i stayed on the line with her until i
got outside and saw the ambulance so i
could
tell her where where we were heading at
what hospital
um so were you kind of hopping because
you fractured i was
i was kind of limping yeah
the the hip fracture i could even hear
like a little clicking
in my because i'd actually dislocated
part of my thigh muscle from my hip
that had to be reattached in surgery but
the real pain
it is our bodies are so resilient i
don't know if you've had any extensive
injuries like that but like
when you break a bone and you have that
kind of injury your body goes into
self-preservation mode
and you don't you legitimately don't
feel anything yeah
massive amount of endorphins for a while
and then it started to kick in when i
got to the hospital they gave me some
uh they gave me fentanyl at the once i
got into the ambulance
which scared me because um you know
there's obviously a fair amount of
deaths associated with abusive fentanyl
and they're like no no it's i mean we
have a medical graduate now we know the
dosage
like okay great um but once i got to the
hospital it started to come on the pain
by the time that my girlfriend had
gotten there actually it just started
rising and that was intense
then they had to they had to reset my
left wrist
to my my left hand to my wrist and in
order to do that they said we're going
to give you
ketamine and we're going to give you a
fair amount of ketamine that is that
will disassociate you from the moment
you won't be aware of what's happening
but you will be awake
i thought okay they gave me the the
ketamine and that
sent me into this like it was such a
trip man
i don't know if you've ever had ketamine
a k-hole it is
like a slightly different dimension of
what you're in now currently
yeah and it felt a little scary slightly
i remember feeling it was like a little
dystopian
a little creepy um i remember i
literally said
it's like i'm in a jodorowsky film
it was scary yeah anyway wow and did you
change the filters didn't make it to the
filters no
i think i actually fell with one of the
filters in my hand
probably saved you yeah put it under
your head there you go
and then what was the other thing it was
about elijah's eyesight your eyes you
wear contact lenses
your eyes are quite bad aren't they yeah
and they're probably worse now than they
were then
but yeah oh i mean i i can't see
anything i'm nearsighted so
i remember being astounded in new
zealand when you told me that you didn't
change
your contact lenses just back then i
didn't yeah
back then i wore lenses i would wear
them a month at a time
and that was a that was at a time where
you weren't supposed to right yeah
was it just the mornings were hard my
eyes became so resilient i remember the
very first time i slept in them
i was probably 10 or 11 years of age and
it was
impossibly painful i accidentally slept
in them woke up
and my eyes were sort of welded shut and
it was extremely extremely painful
but then after that my eyes just were so
resilient
and i would wear
now i take them out every night and i
wear i wear um dailies
so i don't have to clean them and i
don't have to deal with solution i just
put them pop them in throw them away at
night
but the irony is now you there are types
of contact lenses that you can wear for
a month at a time sure back then there
weren't you could well you've got to
clean them and all that don't you is
that
you did you just kept them in i never
just slept in them and then
you'd have like 10 minutes of yeah just
like a little crustiness in the morning
and away we go
crazy yeah the only thing about the ones
that you throw away apparently in the
ocean now a lot of fish
are wearing them i don't need them right
because i was going to say
yeah if it was a fish that's
long-sighted
great fantastic opportunity in life
three or four times i can see oh you
guys
is that a shark and it can get out of
the way i can see the plankton
i can read the newspaper without needing
to
guys we're going to run out of time here
come on we're going to have to invite
you back
i got to come back yeah you got to come
back we'll should we do
should we eat the world right as you
probably know
bill and dom eat the world where we eat
things
from different places in the world yeah
that they might be known for a certain
type of food let's eat the world let's
do that i'd
actually done a little song for this oh
go on johnny you're coming in with the
oh our illustrious producer john is
coming in with uh
napkins and forks and stuff so
if someone wants to slap some drum and
bass on this maybe sample it
i can't really i can't base thing not
you i mean the
the people back home when they listen to
this okay it's half
it's a half-finished song sometimes it's
a waffle
one time it's a plum eating the world
eating the world eating the world with
billy and dom
and elijah hey we'll put a larger
parenthesis there that's great that was
very good
you know very good put some bpms on
there maybe a symbol
right elijah do you want to be the the
do the honors sure
as they say what have we got here ladies
and gentlemen
elijah's girlfriend who he
has a child with is from denmark
wonderful country and i have been
informed that in denmark one of their
traditional dishes
pickled herring we can we can translate
for you
a pickled herring you see pickled
herring
oh we've got plates here and balls oh i
was so excited
i don't think it's something that should
be served in a bowl no it shouldn't
it should be more of a saucer thank you
sir
um oh it's got a it's strong oh
i'll tell you what there's a scent to a
pickled herring there is it there's a
bowl billy give us a bowl there's three
you've got three of them oh god you
threw them over no you didn't
ready yeah it's coming like a frisbee
yeah
and there's one for lunch yeah i'll take
that oh i love that thank you elijah
welcome thank you what apologies
here he comes apology acceptance that i
will leave behind
um this is the kind of thing you
wouldn't bring on a flight is it no
no so uh pickled herring is not
necessarily specific
to denmark very scandinavian though
scandinavian
um but this is sort of an approximation
of
small smarbro which is
uh essentially oh i think actually the
smart means
buttered i believe bread and bro bro
it's very difficult to pronounce danish
is bread
so it's anything red
all right so and so it's basically so
this is
i brought um a danish rye that i've that
i've pre-sliced for this well thank you
um
and you know in denmark there are
restaurants that are devoted to just
this thing
very very traditional it's almost like a
danish taco the idea is
you have the the traditional rye bread
and anything can go on top from fried
fish to
vegetables whatever combination that you
can think of
obviously herring is a very traditional
little shrimps little prawns i've seen
that
yeah sure they eat a lot of that around
there don't they hold on
guys there's a now i would say
you could describe the smell more as a
stench
than a smell would that be accurate
there's a there's a stench
well as i see you it's pickled fish
isn't it it is pickle fish
certainly pickled fish elijah's fire
hold on hang on all right get as close
to the microphone when you're eating it
we need the
mastication is very important oh yeah i
mean
oh and you would you would you would
traditionally have this with
schnapps or aquavit aquavit yeah yeah
it's vinegary it's fishy fishy i'm
loving it
hold on i'm going to have another goal
because it's quite a shock
on your first bite elijah yeah we're
going to give you the categories
in which we rate these things so that
you can have a thing
the first one you're right bills i'm
already
stuck man and you too oh my throat
billy's been suffering from throat
issues today i'm quite worried about him
i'm just worried that i was
i was going to get some hair in the lung
quite hard to get out of there once it's
in
so we rate we rate our eating the world
based on
taste out of ten billy i always forget
the other two
um um taste out of ten
taste out of ten also um aesthetics
ah the look the feel the vibe whatever
okay
the whole ambiance of it all and also um
the usefulness yeah flexibility
like a flexibility almost fullness yeah
yeah of this thing like can i use this
is this going to come in handy
these were billies these were billy's
categories
billy would you like if you're in the
house and you'd pickle herring right and
all you've got
and a bagel some crackers
and a piece of cheese would you think to
yourself that's useful right now yeah
or um you know how useful is it in the
house
when you don't have a lot of other stuff
you know at one point
yeah i do at one point at one point
we're probably going to do marmite
because you know ma
might such as yeah now marmite's
fantastic it's not necessarily useful
honestly here's a question
when it comes to marmite and vegemite
where do you stand i'm a marmite guy
right vegemite's australian is it is it
that's that's the distinction yeah but
it also and new zealand isn't it
yeah new zealand do their own version of
marmite and their own version of
vegemite but we're the original we
england created the original right
wasn't it an accident yeah i think it
was born out of the beer making
industry right the dregs of yeast right
and they recognized that there was a
flavor to that that was really good and
they
packaged it with your girlfriend being
danish do you eat a lot of scandinavian
danish type food there's not a lot in
los
angeles true it's the problem um do you
know soccer bit
oh my god are you on the third street in
the sweet show yeah
come on incredible oh yeah by the pound
buy the pounds it's actually very good
for your pickled herrings you know
is it yeah because of these omega-3s and
also your vitamin d3 that's right yeah
so um
lots of omegas omega three maybe omega-6
which are probably very good
yeah very good for you fish is very good
for you very good for you
what else do you know about pickled
herring i'm just looking now i'm
cheating
do you know anything i'm cheating here
at home hang on i'm going to read a
little piece here pickled herring
especially
brined herring it's common in russia and
ukraine where elijah and i have both
word
where it is served cut into pieces
seasoned with sunflower oil and onions
like this
yeah or can be part of herring salads
such as dressed herring
there's also a lot of dill dill is
pretty prevalent in a lot of
scandinavian food as well
how was sweden i'd really liked that do
you guys and see
these sort of russian sort of uh states
i i was doing i was uh working over in
lithuania wow and i was i was in the
hotel and i went down for breakfast
and the first day i was there i had the
normal breakfast
eggs whatever blah blah and then it was
the second day
over in the corner there was something
and i thought what is that there
and i took a walk over to this ice
mountain
caveat like honestly
ten different types of caviar for
breakfast breakfast what do you think
what do you want
with the little little pancakes cheese
cream all this stuff oh elijah
i couldn't sleep at night but thinking
about getting up for this caveat salty
though
salty love it so good for you as well
and then the waiter would come over
would you like
eggs no i don't want eggs
have you seen the mountain over there of
caviar
i'll be eating that until i'm sick
[Applause]
and it was fantastic and it was free
and it was well it was your breakfast
that was just your breakfast because
caviar is very expensive
not in lithuania wow they'll serve you
that like it's a boiled egg
i love the caviar scene in in big you
know where he tries it for the first
time
oh it's great back to the pickled
herring we've got to give it marks out
of 30.
so that's separated into three ten and
ten i got it do you want me to go first
to give you an idea
of how we go about this yeah you can
give you can do decimal points
okay i didn't know that until last week
he put an eight point four and i
didn't you're like oh we're doing
decimal points yeah i don't know why we
didn't make it
100 anyway good point
taste i'm giving it an 8.2
nice because it's high in taste it's
delicious
but it's a shock the first time you bite
into it yeah
so that took off a point straight away
yeah you've got to be ready for it
maybe the stench is what helps you get
ready i like the shock
i find it quite refreshing i was like oh
i didn't expect it to be that
strong right check the sale by date yeah
i thought
but i carried on yeah for looks
i'm not going to give a high on looks
other than
i like how dense it is yeah the
denseness is good
so i'm only going to give that a 6.2
and for usefulness it's not that useful
no
i'm not going to put it on a pizza no no
no no i mean not very versatile
it's not versatile yeah you're not going
to stir it into soup
no no no no no you eat it with a hard
brown bread
yeah which is the only other flavor that
will go with it yeah
so i'm going to have to give it a three
point six okay versatility yeah fair
enough
fair enough large all right uh i'd say a
nine for flavor
it's superb i love it tasty i love it i
love all things pickled though i love
i love briny pickley things sweet and
otherwise
um what's the next one appearance
appearance appearance
i mean it's not the most aesthetically
beautiful
food no it's the bastard child of
pickled fish i'd say
a seven maybe a seven
yeah i mean think of some beauty think
of some japanese
food that you may have had sure some
sushi i mean they've taken the same fish
at some point
i will say and they've made it look prey
it's true i will say a proper small bow
if
you were to get it in a restaurant might
be more beautiful
yeah um i'm getting better at it
usefulness
i gotta go low on usefulness yeah this
is a difficult one but we're keeping it
yeah we'll keep it
i think um
here's the thing that's that that makes
it more useful
okay is that you can uh you don't have
to cook it
the preparation is that you right out of
the jar
uh-huh you can eat it so so you can have
it on a car journey i feel like it's
more useful
than yeah maybe you can have it in your
glass this is
a 4.7
yeah from what large is saying there
potentially and bear with me for a
second it's wonderful
bear with me for a second you could put
a jar of pickled herring in your glove
box
and then while you're driving you could
ask the passenger to pass it over to you
and
hopefully open it for you so you don't
have to do it yourself and then as
you're driving down the motorway you
could just
drink drink it and then i
got a big bit in there do you remember
speaking of this reminds me of pickled
onions
do you remember who used to eat a lot of
pickled onions is it our friend mark
no on the set of lord of the rings oh
peter jackson loves her pickled onions
onions
and cheese and cubes of cheese and then
you come over really close to you
and you go i want you to be really
scared in this moment
and you go i am i'm scared of your
breath pete get away
it's awful it's awful i love him too
i love him can i tell you what my
favorite pickle is of all time
because they do them here the pickled
hot chili peppers you know the
the yellow banana peppers great oh that
in the morning
come on come on so good not as good as a
pickled onion though
love it chips two pickled onions
so good lovely yeah i'm getting into the
chips i love sauerkraut as well oh i
love salad
and the sauerkraut juice i will drink
yeah it's supposed to be very good for a
hangover
i'm gonna give my scores taste yes
i'm just getting a bit off the back of
my tooth there yeah 9.2
oh it's up there i loved it i absolutely
loved it
looks i'm with you guys i'm gonna say
it a one point seven that's nice
pretty that's an ugly thing i think the
taste the taste could
stop you from trying it if you weren't
brave like we were the look
the look i'm sorry the look and then
usefulness yeah
uh i'll be charitable 3.5
right okay it's not that yes i loved it
though i absolutely love it
there's a place in copenhagen that next
time you're there uh you should go
it's an institution i think it's like a
hundred years old this place called
chinaman's
and it's not easy to get every time
we've we've been
we couldn't manage to get a table and we
finally got a table this last trip which
just was just before lockdown so the
last time i was in
denmark i was there with you almost yes
we almost we almost saw your show and we
had to go yeah yeah
wow so yeah we managed to go to
shenandoah
i just thought you were sneezing it is
incredible it's that is their specialty
and it's every variety of
of small blood that you can think of
it's awesome so awesome i could go that
right now
that's so good do you guys not think
because we're gonna finish and like
schnapps oh my god oh schnapps
like dill aquavid and all these
different flavors of aquavit
so good yeah i lived in sweden for like
nine months oh i love sweden and our
friend jason came over and we did an
an absolutely no expenses spared
smorgasbord which took like four or five
hours and it was incredible
awesome i know you have to go live and
we'll have you come back whenever you
want because we've got so much to talk
about and we didn't touch upon anything
but very quickly do you guys not think
it's really interesting that
how long have you been married bills uh
don't get in trouble with your eyes for
god's sake 13 years what year is it here
2021 21 10 11 12.
you've been 11 you've been married for
12 years you've got a 15 year old son
elijah you've been with your girlfriend
for how long five years you've got a 20
month old
son but the gay rumors are still kind of
circulating around with the three of us
do you know is that true here well i do
this q a
on instagram yeah and you know there's
questions all right
i see that on your on your stories or
whatever yeah guaranteed
at least i would say ten questions we
just saw one are you gay are you an
elijah gay
are you and billy married you your
answer actually was really sweet
your answer was well considering the
fact that you know both
bill and elijah are fathers and you know
uh like you know yeah
like work with the science here someone
asked me
someone asked me is billy's son also
your son
and i was like well how does that even
buy allegedly
work well it's questions doesn't it do
you know what i mean questions
i think it's probably because we're all
together yeah yeah we're just closer
[Music]
i know you have to leave live what about
the um is there a music thing
oh we've got do you want if you get time
for the music thing should we do the
music thing
this is a new thing this is a new
regular
feature of the show inspired by elijah
jordan wood because you're such a big
fan of music
called funky for you where we
we ask our guest or someone that phones
into the show
to pick 10 seconds of a song and we ask
is that funky for you for you so elijah
what have you picked for us
i have picked the opening 10 seconds of
a song called halalua
by can the german cat rock band can
let's do it
pump it up chris let's hear it i know
you're not called chris john
[Music]
how are we we've not even talked about
how we're gonna rate these schools we
don't it's because we don't even know
this is uncharted territory
play that again i liked it so much
player good job
here we go i like that
drum is extraordinary
it's an 18-minute song get the heck out
18 minutes
uh there's a single edit on on 45
uh that's three just under four minutes
and that's
that's what i've dj'd with that it's so
great because it just condenses the best
bits
into it like a little less than four
minutes but yeah it's an 18 minute song
it's so good
i think i'd suggest it to you that maybe
we rate it
the funk basedness of it
on brahms at the lower level of
funk because we all know that brahms was
an extraordinary musician but i don't
think anyone would describe him as
a funky music name and at the very top
did we say prince what princess funky
prince
is the funk and we can go anything in
between
for me i enjoyed that very much i love
it as the start of a song
which is very important so i'm glad that
you took the start of a song
elijah and that really drew me in
as you see the drummond tape tastes
tight
and then when that came in with i liked
it i liked a lot i'm going to say that
was very funky
yeah but do you want to mention a
musician based on the rate of the funk
i mean it's up there as with you as with
james brown nice
that's james brown james brown funky wow
that is
that's really getting up there funky i
was going to say
early jimi hendrix funk okay funky
yeah there's a little bit of room to go
yeah
large i would put this in the
um i would put this in the early
the early parliament funkadelic fund
oh it's a deep cut i know it's a deep
cut it's very fun
yeah funkadelic i would say i love it
yeah early funkadelic
it's made me want to listen to the rest
of it same so that's good i think yeah
yeah it's a real hook those drums are
amazing
anyone out there if you want to suggest
10 seconds of music to us get in touch
on our voicemail or you can email us
the friendship onion at castmedia.com
that's cass with the k and it's fun this
notion of 10 seconds is so rad too
because there are
bits in songs excuse me that that
otherwise aren't funky but it breaks
down into something funky yes
for instance at the end of
optimistic before it goes into tree
fingers is that what it is
yeah um there's there's a little
breakdown like
it goes funky for like 10 seconds and
then it goes into another thing
and just to clarify for anyone out there
that wants to play that was a radiohead
by the way radiohead just to clarify for
anyone out there that wants to play
along this
it doesn't necessarily just need to be
funk of course james brown is funky and
prince is funky and parliament are funky
but radiohead can be funky exactly uh
the beatles can be funky
uh macy gray can be funky there's a
whole bunch of things that make you jump
up and down oh man i mean the opening of
um speaking of the beatles um sergeant
peppers sergeant pepper reprise free
press
oh we used to do a monster monster yeah
that is a smash
oh well i remember talking to you people
are like ringo is
[ __ ] off he's an amazing ringo is
incredible amazing
remember we had talked about in new
zealand the break
i think it's the middle eight type vibe
break in pump up the volume
by mars there's a funky break in that
which is just incredible i can't
i can't recall it but um yeah watchman
watch him
do it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah there you go um lars you have to go
i gotta go
i'm gonna ask one more question and it's
kind of a one-word answer and this will
be the thing that
will slay the two of you ready
you have to pick you're on a desert
island and you have to pick
the entire back catalogue of either
one of these three bends or musicians
prince david bowie
or radiohead who are you gonna pick
and this will end the show i know that's
really hard
i know prince prince really yeah
and it's yeah i mean it goes without
saying like radiohead or
it's it's a tough call i would go david
bowie and i don't think we need to
explain ourselves
let's just leave it like that prince
will you come back i would love to
we did yeah i feel like we've only we
barely scratched the surface we scrolled
through
probably less than a third of the show
and i wanted to is that your is that
your series of notes i wanted to ask you
about
being famous
usb what does that mean well i just just
the fact that
the three of us have been famous for
more than half of our life
so the idea of being famous to us
is so kind of just it will it's just who
we are type thing
i wanted to swim through those murky
depths but we didn't get there
we will we oh we'll get there we did the
bowie prince thing
i wanted to talk about are those jelly
beans on your
on your socks they are look at that
thank you jelly bean sauce oh i have one
more thing this is i have to tell you
this
all right otherwise my my parents will
kill me at one point
you had post this is years ago you had
posted
on facebook so sad to be leaving austin
i look forward to being back there soon
and my dad whose name is austin
had written to you on that same feed and
said oh elijah i didn't know that you
cared
and he didn't write back which is fine
because you didn't see it it is
i think my dad's favorite joke of all
time that's a great job he said can you
please ask elijah if it resonated and i
said to my dad this morning
i don't even think elijah saw it so no
because if i had i think you would have
written absolutely written
so sad to be leaving austin talking
about my favorite jokes ever
another question i was going to ask you
but we'll get around to it next time
is will you wear wigs oh
we should have done and and we'll again
we'll we'll break that down
at another point live it's been great to
see you this has been so good you guys
wonderful so fun
we'll see you next week guys goodbye
you